so why should you use index DB over web
sequel well the good side is that index
DB is supported in chrome including
Chrome for Android as well as Firefox ie
and opera the downside is that it's not
supported in the old Android browser or
in Safari so there are going to be a
bunch of mobile users out there that
don't have ID be support for a while of
course there are a bunch of mobile users
out there that aren't going to have web
sequel support either so what's a web
developer to do well in general i like
to recommend trying to do the right
thing but pragmatically making it work
in tough situations the answer here is
right to index DB but use a polyfill so
it will work on web sequel browsers a
good polyfill to use is the index DB
shim there's a link down in the
instructor notes writing your code this
way you can write good index DB code but
it'll still work on Safari or other
browsers that don't yet support index DB